megan the stallion
setting the record straight the rapper
says she's currently recovering from
gunshot wounds sustained from a quote
traumatic night over the weekend
here's what we know on monday tmz
initially reported that police responded
to a disturbance call in the hollywood
hills early sunday morning
with witnesses directing them to an suv
that megan
rapper tori lanes and another unknown
woman were riding in together
the report also stated that megan had
received a cut on her foot from a piece
of broken glass
and that police had found a gun in the
vehicle
e.t later confirmed that torrey was
arrested on a felony charge and was
released on a 35 thousand dollar bond on
sunday and on wednesday the savage
rapper took to instagram to reveal new
details about the night
calling earlier reports about the
incident quote inaccurate
she wrote on sunday morning i suffered
gunshot wounds as a result of a crime
that was committed against me
and done with the intention to
physically harm me megan went on to note
that
she was never arrested and that police
officers actually helped her
driving her to the hospital to undergo
surgery to remove the bullets
she added quote i'm incredibly grateful
to be alive and that i'm expected to
make a full recovery but
it was important for me to clarify the
details about this traumatic night
she captioned the post this whole
experience was an eye-opener and a
blessing in disguise
i hate that it took this experience for
me to learn how to protect my
energy e.t has reached out to reps for
megan and tori for comment